The joe rogan experience,
you know,
and I think first of all,
those style of comedy that
you and I come from too,
you get very spoiled at it for a
certain particular type of colleague.
Boston comedy is a very
specific kind of comedy.
If you stop and think about how many
good comics have come from Boston,
you know,
Jay Leno came from Boston.
Steven Wright came from Boston guys
that people don't know that it probably
better than 90% of the fucking
people that are like big name comics.
Like Gavin,
Don Gavin,
one of the funniest guys ever
walked the face of the earth.
He's,
he's a monster.
He's a masterful king like the east coast,
I think all the way down to like DC,
the amount of guys.
But I think that Boston was a rare place
because we're from Boston does have a
lot of it in and leave.
They didn't leave.
Those guys stayed there.
No one left Boston,
the big monsters.
Steve Sweeney,
Kenny Rogers,
Sin Those Don Gavin,
Mike Donovan when I was a kid.
Okay.
And I and I,
when I first started doing open mics
there and those guys were all the national
headliners or the the
local headliners rather,
they'd be at Nick's and they'd be it.
You have the connection.
I remember sitting there watching those
guys and they would kind of like some
like national guy would come through like
Billy crystal and Billy crystal would
come through and they
would put on dawn Gavin,
Steve Sweeney and fucking and Lenny
Clarke in a row and then bring up Billy
crystal and it wasn't fair.
They did it on purpose.
They knew that the level of comedy was
so high there and these guys were only
doing 20 minutes tight
to say 20 minutes doing.
A lot of them were doing local references.
Dude,
I don't give up.
If you put on for local
headliners in front of me,
if I'm on the road,
yeah,
I'm fucked.
You're fucked.
You're fucked for the first couple of
minutes until you can get them into your
groove.
But people love local Shit and Boston,
especially Boston is such a,
a city that in love
with being from Boston,
so it's done of them was one of my faith
and his name doesn't get brought up but
not enough topic that he
used to do that joke about.
Uh,
had some,
he,
his comedy was so blue
collar and I was coming up,
uh,
you know,
working at warehouses and stuff.
It was where my,
both my parents were professional,
white collar,
but I was a moron,
so fucked up in school.
So I had like blue collar jobs.
So his comedy was just
right out over the place.
He did something,
he had some sort of back and forth with
the boss and he made this reference,
you know,
basically tell him the
boss to go fuck himself.
He said,
I'll take a 20 minutes,
shit on the clock if I want to.
And I fucking fell out because there
was always that lazy fuck wouldn't help
unload the trucks.
He had every God damn trick in the Book
and how to somehow make that eight hour
day go by.
And one of them was when he grabbed the
Herald and the globe to go take a shit
and it would somehow take like
fucking 40 minutes every day.
Donovan was a,
he's another one.
He's a master.
There was a bunch of guys
that were around back then.
I mean there's still around.
I'm sure Donald when you,
if you live in Boston you could probably
find them headline and somewhere and
he's still doing comedy,
I'm sure.
Right?
I know he ran a foul into
the IRS for a bit o the,
a lot of those guys that were working
for cash for a long time and they weren't
paying tax.
I didn't hear anything about that.
I heard they will all up to date.
I don't know.
I'm talking about,
yeah,
you're right.
You know what?
I miss her.
I miss heard those,
those guys out in Long Island.
I makes some of them.
Did I miss her?
Oh,
here's another one.
It doesn't get brought up teddy burrs.
Ron,
do you ever get a chance to teddy bears?
Holy Shit.
That guy was good.
Let me tell you something.
I saw that guy in 1988 I was at an open
mic night and it was one of the first
times that I've thought
about quitting comedy.
He went to,
yeah,
it was an open mic night
and I went up and I,
you know,
I did my little five
minutes of fucking nonsense,
stupid,
terrible,
bad comedy.
Just trying to make people laugh,
didn't know what the fuck I was
doing and didn't go so good.
You know those early sets.
It was like one of my
third or fourth sets,
some not so good,
clumsy,
you know,
maybe one laugh and then I fuck it up
with a swag punchline and I just didn't
know it as known.
Teddy bears run.
It goes up and just so fucking smooth,
smooth and relaxed and the way he
would talk just like mesmerizing.
And I had heard about his tonight show,
fucking said he had just done the tonight
show and somebody had a video of it
and they played the video and
he plays the fucking piano.
He does like this,
talks about commercials and he
plays the piano and talks about it.
It's so fucking smooth and so good.
You would look at them and go,
okay,
this guy's going to be gigantic.
This guy's going to be bigger than,
than Robin Williams.
He's going to be the biggest
stand up comic of the country.
Never left Boston.
Just stayed.
Yeah,
they are staying.
I don't,
yeah,
they will.
They would.
It was like were like townies,
but uh,
but comedians,
but that guy got work,
the all got work in Boston.
They didn't have to leave.
See when they were working at Nick's
comedy stop and they were working at,
you know,
stitches and all these different clubs,
they can hop around from club to club.
Like there's a that,
that um,
you've said that documentary and France,
Alameda did.
Standup stood out.
Yeah.
And,
and you know,
Lindy Clark talks about all
the different sets that he did.
He would do all these different sets of
night and we'd go from here to there.
They are there and
they're there in clothes.
They'd be making 1500 bucks a night.
Yeah.
And he's just hire a driver just to
wait outside and do all this sets.
What I loved about those guys is there
was almost like a height requirement to
like they will all like fucking six,
two,
six,
three huge guys and they
could like literally would
have like a keg of beer over
one shoulder and like an eight ball in
their hand and we'd just be going from
Club to club,
destroys drawing and demurred and do it
below all the way just to keep that buzz
going and then,
and then at the end of the night,
dude,
I heard some fuck that.
That back at Nick's man.
Somebody.
Yeah they offered to pay me in coke.
Yeah
they would offer to pay you in coke.
Yeah that was the deal.
Did they give you do coke?
Oh no we can pay in coke.
No I'll take care.
Yeah,
take fuck.
Like I thought that was a joke.
I didn't realize they pay you in coke.
They will be offered to pay you and coke
and they do a lot of guys did a lot of
guys some
of their money in coke cause I guess
are comedians and porn stars to two
careers.
I couldn't get paid and coke
if it had to come to it.
Yeah,
I would
say probably bands too.
Bands,
a portion of the boxers back in the Dj's,
they give you some
chips you have see that.
I know it was just a photo op thing.
We ever see that,
that great picture of
Sonny Liston where he's a,
it looks like he just knocked somebody
out and he's sitting there still in his
box of trunks.
Hands taped up.
I think his hands on.
But I that had to been a promotional.
Even even those mob guys would be like,
come on Sunday.
Don't you think the starting on Boston
was like one of the best places you could
have ever chose to begin
your comedy career?
I think about that a lot.
So Lanette,
whenever I think about that
cause when did you start?
What year?
I started in March of 92.
Uh,
it was like 23,
almost 24,
so I started a little bit late and
I remember just some of the times,
like when I've gone on the road and a,
and you meet the young
up and coming guys like,
yeah,
the comedy scene here sucks and Blah,
blah blah blah blah.
Like they,
it sucks so bad.
Like don't even know what to do.
And you always tell them,
we'll just go out and start a room.
Like some of them,
like,
you know the scene so bad,
they don't even think of doing that.
It's like what even start roaming,
say go pick a fucking sports bar
that does no business on a Monday,
Tuesday and tell them that you're
going to get people in here,
you know,
lie to them that they,
you're going to get people to come in
to watch these fucking open miker is do
five minutes each day.
The first time I ate my
fucking balls on stage,
I was doing this place like Kelly's
something or other in either reading or
north Redding.
It doesn't exist anymore.
This comedian,
Jack Lynch booked it and there would
literally be like a Bruins game on TV
and they wouldn't shut the game off.
Fuck no,
no.
You got to do comedy over the game and
the volume for the game was still on too.
Yeah.
A lot of those gigs down the Cape.
I did a lot of those gigs and you'd
find out the fucking game was on.
Why you got to like fuck the game.
Are they going to leave the game on?
There was like an always an issue.
You're going to leave the game and said
[inaudible] we're going to turn the game
off.
They would turn the game
I've ever been to go,
what the fuck I fucking shot.
Nick came off,
he shot in the foot and then you would
have to go do comedy for a bunch of
people were angry at you
for shutting the game.
Oh,
it was brutal.
And I remember the second
question other than,
uh,
are you going to,
are you going to shut the game off?
Is,
is,
is there a stage that was another thing.
So you just stand,
you just stammered over that dude.
I remember doing a Gig,
this is how green we are,
where it was me,
uh,
Al del,
Benny,
Patrice O'Neil,
and I want to say Dane Cook was
on it and we were so Bobby Kelly,
I think it was his gig that he booked.
We were so green and years
later I finally figured it out.
They gave us this microphone.
It was a lapel mic.
Oh my God.
We had to go up and do comedy with
just like a lapel on like we were doing
Letterman,
but we were so green.
We didn't know that you
clipped it on cereal.
All standing there holding,
I swear to God,
holding a lapel mic.
I remember portrays he's like fucking six
five hold it because I remember that's
right.
Dell Benny Ldl Benny was hosting is like,
what the fuck is up with this Mike?
He's like,
this is the smallest Mike ever.
I'll look,
I'll put it in.
Aunt had it in his mouth and
we're all laughing at them like,
yeah,
what a half fast fucking Gig.
And we were so stupid that we didn't
understand what it was and like he would
let it,
Al would bring me up and then hand me
the mic like a tea cup with his pinkies
out picky out and I would just be like,
hey,
keep it going.
[inaudible] and my dad was,
he was pretty nuts growing up with like
three fingers up in the air holding this
thing
and I went from that to two
from from going to taekwondo,
straight into going to comedy,
kickboxing.
I had a few key three kickboxing fights
and then I went right into comedy
because I knew I was going nowhere
so there's no money in it.
What's your opening like standup?
Was it about like no knighting?
Yeah.
No,
I never talked to him.
Really intense was like,
hello,
this is my comedy.
No,
I tried to do it.
You got to talk about your life.
We never talked about that.
There's no one wants to take some
fucking guys on martial arts champion.
That's the thing because he was actually
good at it like this that you've got to
be of like low self esteem.
You could say,
you know,
if you can say,
ah,
I find a taekwondo tournament once and
I fought on Friday and when I finally
woke up on Tuesday,
you know,
after something.
Yeah.
So now I'm doing comedy.
I think we would like,
you can't
say that.
Oh,
so I was,
I fucking kicked this dude in the
head and knocked him into a coma.
That's not funny,
Dude.
What am I,
when I,
when I started out though,
there was like,
you know,
because all those,
all those headliners didn't leave.
We were like kind of fucked
the end up headlining.
We were looking at the only guys who
kind of busted through was you and a
Anthony Clark with the two guys at the
time who would actually somehow gotten
past the old boy network.
Yeah.
Well they left WWE,
you know,
Anthony was one of the,
and Nick Depaula left too.
They just left.
You know,
you had to leave.
You can't stay in Boston.
It was so intoxicating
because you can make a living.
You could be in Boston and
unit if you were a nobody,
you know,
you're still,
you could grind out 500 bucks a week,
you know you'd do here,
do here.
It was as long as you're
willing to drive and travel.
If you had $500 cash a week,
you could pay for your bills.
You could eat.
But if you want to try to go on the road,
man,
good fucking luck.
Yeah.
No TV credits,
no nothing.
Just some guy from Boston.
How much are they going to pay you?
But you're fucking gas.
Your air fare is going to
eat up all your profits.
It's fucking hard.
What are you,
uh,
what do you think now?
Cause I just went back to Boston.
Have you been back there later?
Yeah.
It's sad.
It's nothing going on there now.
What?
He's the fucking,
the comedy connections.
A theater now,
you know,
it's that big Wilbur theater,
right?
Comedy can actually use to be 150 seats.
That ban has a little room and now it's,
you know,
no,
but they,
they reopened that right up the street.
The old Charles Street playhouse.
Yeah.
What's it now?
What's another comedy song called?
I can't remember this one.
Small one in Faneuil hall called Motley's.
I did that and that Tim Mackenzie's place,
I can't remember.
I did it.
I ran through all of them.
There was 80 it was like,
and that was like an 85 seater.
I did Dick Dorothy's comedy fault,
but I put together my basically polished
up my first five minutes of material
ever.
So I always go down there.
The vault,
I did them all.
Oh yeah,
dude,
I fucking loved that place and this
is a thing hasn't changed at all.
Like I remember when that place started
is a fucking old I am now and now it's,
they just like celebrate,
aren't they?
I see Tim Mckenzie,
I'm sorry if he's listening.
Tim Mcintyre,
I think it started
in 93 yeah.
Why was it?
Yeah,
I was a year earlier than that,
son.
No,
no,
no.
The Vault,
Dick tardies.
Comedy Vault.
That shit was around in the 80s all right.
Because in 88 when I was around the Dick
doughty commie vault was around Dick
Towards town.
REMINGTON's yeah.
That fucking bank.
It's like a bank.
Wow.
I saw it.
I thought Spike Tobin was the
first guy who opened that shit up.
It might have reopened it.
Mighta reopened it.
Okay.
That's what might've went under.
And they brought it back.
But Dick is comedy vault was a staple
back when I was living there and I moved
out of Boston like 92.
Yeah,
you were gone before I wrote.
When I started.
You were already gone.
Um,
yeah.
What the fuck was I working at?
I think I was,
first time I saw,
I saw you what?
The cow alone.
Oh,
that place.
That was a good place.
Yeah.
Always food is Chinese food and comedy
still Chinese food and comedy's a weird
combination of exist in Boston.
Like the biggest,
the most famous historical Comedy Club
in Boston was the Ding Ho so Chinese
restaurant that they had comedy out of.
And now the only place that
exists that place had a,
uh,
Rick Jenkins runs.
He runs a place in Cambridge.
Yeah.
And that's the,
uh,
that's another Chinese restaurant,
restaurant,
his restaurant and upstairs
you can comedy labs.
I what they call it.
Yeah,
I remember the,
uh,
the act,
the cool,
cool,
cool.
And then the other places might,
Clark's plays giggles and Saugus.
Yeah.
You know,
but there's more work in Boston or the,
at least there was like
just little road gigs,
an hour drive here,
hour drive there,
more of those in that area than
anywhere else in the country.
Know what I would talk to guys from
like other places and then I'm like,
where's your road gigs?
Or where do you go for road gigs?
Oh,
you know,
sometimes I do Ohio sometimes.
Like what do you got?
No,
don't you have gigs around here?
Like no one could make
a living around there.
Yeah.
But Lord or something,
nobody,
nobody would start like,
I don't know what it is.
I bought,
people would just start rooms,
don't have a Bob Marley out of Maine.
He came down like a fully formed fucking
headliner just because he had like 25
rooms going up in Maine.
Like he started basically
it was like Mcdonald's,
but he started with like comrades.
He used to tell me when he was living
up there and it was getting so big,
he actually ended up leaving
because he almost became,
I think like a kind of almost
like a club owner at that point.
He could have done it.
But um,
he basically started the
comedy scene up there.
Cause before that all they
had was like the connection.
But like Portland.
Yeah.
And he,
he started like he had at any time
I used to do gigs in Bangor
and Bob would do like,
guess bots and shit when
he was first starting out.
Bobby,
I don't know if you know
how famous he is in Maine,
do you know?
Yeah,
no,
no.
Yeah.
He's like,
if you don't know who Bob
Marley is a very funny guy,
very nice guy.
I've known him for fucking 20 plus years.
Always been just a great guy.
But when he first started out,
you know,
there was like,
this is like,
you know,
probably he probably started in 89 or 90.
There's no one known
from being from Maine.
There's no like one main
comic that stands up,
but Bob Marley in anywhere
else in the country is like,
people might have heard of them.
You might have heard him on Xm radio,
you might have seen him on comedy
central or something in Maine.
That motherfucker is huge.
If there's no comparison,
it's like Blasius or Gabriel
Iglesias and in La is giant.
Gabriel Iglesias does shows in La.
Well he'll do like five
shows on a Monday night,
like something fucking nutty and sell
out everyone like days and days in
advance.
That's how he is.
Nobody else was like,
yeah,
no.
He used to go,
I remember he was telling me he would
basically be in La auditioning and then
every year,
right,
it's the holidays came around.
He would make like 10 times what I made
on the road in that month just as she'll
be talking about is money.
But yeah,
he would just go up there and do parties
and then he do the new year's thing and
there's this one we would like,
he would do like a,
like a 1500 2000 seat or need to be
doing like adding shows and shit.
Yeah.
And doing all this main material,
you know,
so much main.
Like I was listening to them on the
radio the other day was on Xm radio.
I was doing all these main jokes in it.
He was doing them in Maine.
They were going crazy.
They were fucking
no in the he also dude
he has like a box set.
That's how many albums
this dude is put out.
He's put out like 16 albums,
14 album's fucking unbelievable.
The amount of hours,
14 hours of fucking money.
I kind of,
I pretty much have stuck close
with the same guys that I started.
Like my graduating class,
Bobby Kelly,
LDL,
Benny,
you know our new bur when I first started.
And Patrice,
um,
cause we kind of came up like a little
bit after you like you were a couple of
years ahead.
Headlines
early on.
I did a bunch of a really a fun
little gigs for dicta already.
The comedy huts.
Remember those comedy Gods in Cambridge?
Did we did Dick towards comedy?
Hung out on the monkeys.
Dane was with a,
a comedy troupe with Bob Kelly
and him and Altel Benny was so,
it was a good comedy troupe.
You guys were funny.
It was good.
You know,
it was interesting.
You would do comedy sketches
and then you would do,
like,
each guy would go up and do stand up,
right?
And so we would work together,
do these uh,
Dick Dardy gaze.
Those were fucking fun.
Our sketch comedy Improv group was,
was so bad.
We were so bad at Improv and everybody,
you know,
the first rule of Improv is don't deny,
but we were so bad at Improv
that our first roles was denied.
So we were just command and
completely ruined scenes by like,
you're pretending pantomiming I'm holding
a baby and just Bobby can be big dude.
Why are you holding a tire?
And you just,
it would just fall apart from there.
But we just had a boy.
You guys have some good ones.
You had some good sketches.
Good.
It was fun.
I mean it was it and it was experimental.
It was like you guys were taking chances.
You were doing something a
little unusual at a comedy club.
Just you were doing comedy too.
Yeah.
That was probably actually better for
us opening with our standup and then we
just go fuck around and do music
or skits or Improv or whatever for,
you know,
whatever the rest of
the hour to fill it out.
But we,
we also,
you know,
we came out of Boston where,
I know the guys that I can't,
I mean I loved,
I love Steve Martin and the guys
that I always loved just watching,
growing up that I wanted to emulate.
And then when I started in Boston,
these guys were like,
killers man.
People don't understand about Boston is
everybody knows all these famous guys.
Everybody knows Billy crystal.
Everybody knows.
You know,
I mean,
and the very good comics,
Robert Klein,
but I Blah Blah Blah would name the Guy
Don Gavin was better than all of them.
Yeah.
He was better than all of them.
And this is,
this is not an exaggeration,
and he was fucking squeaky clean.
I mean,
every now and then he say,
fucking fuck.
Fuck a little listen man.
But his bits,
we're not dirty.
It was delivery was perfect.
It was perfect.
Yeah.
You would watch his economy of words,
the way he set a sentence up
and you would just feel humbled.
You would be like,
fuck,
he's a master.
He's a master.
But he got caught up in this Boston thing
where there's all these great guys in
this one area and they always drew a
crowd and they always got paid well.
And then they would go on the
road and they'd be nobody's.
They'd be like,
why would they be a fucking nobody?
You've got to be back back in Boston.
The next thing you know,
they're back in Boston and they're just
doing the same gigs over and over again.
When everybody else takes a shot and
branches off and disappears and becomes
famous
and you,
but you really would watch these guys
and part of you would feel bad that they
weren't getting over the hump,
but you felt like so fucking honored
to be opening up and standing,
watching going,
I'm learning from the best.
Sure.
When you leave Boston,
it's like you had that
these were guys like,
I always describe it like they
had the energy of showman,
but they were like men.
They were like men doing comedy.
Yes,
yes.
And I,
you know,
I always really wanted to be there.
They always stood right at the
fucking front of the stage.
They were re Lenny Clarke is
the perfect example of that.
When Lenny's a fucking man,
he's the guy.
This is what Larry Clarkson was.
We were at giggles and Sagas and there
was this fucking table full of chicks.
They,
they wouldn't
shut the fuck up.
They were screaming and yelling.
He goes,
listen,
if you don't shut the fuck up,
I'm going to hire a Nigga.
Fuck you in front of your mother.
Like
what the fuck it he does say mean.
It was me.
I take Chris Mcguire was there,
I think it was me and Chris.
I can't remember,
but we were like,
what the fuck did he just say?
He doesn't give a fuck.
Lenny Clarke did not give a fuck.
He was just his big gigantic
burly guy who would,
by the way,
he would beat your ass too.
He would.
This is like,
if you like talk shit to Lenny car,
he'll probably do a line
and punch in the face.
These were real like real
hardcore blue collar guys,
but real king corollary made us,
it made us sharper because you were
held up to a much higher standard.
You had to go on after guys who were
way better than average and you had a,
you had to be sharp all the time.
You had a,
you had to constantly reassess your
material self up for that kind of thing.
I still look back and remember
the first time you ever bombed?
Yeah,
or yeah,
or a bunch of them.
I just wrote,
it's called New York.
I just,
I just wrote a chapter in this book.
I'm writing all on the very
first time I ever bombed,
which was horrible,
terrible disaster that I'll never forget
because it was the first time I ever
bombed while I was getting paid.
Oh Shit.
That's a big difference.
Yeah.
Bomb and open mic nights.
Everybody's bombing,
you know,
it's like there's like five people are
going to eat shit on stage and you're
only up there for five minutes,
but once you do a paid,
and I was middling.
I shouldn't have been middling.
I really didn't have the time.
And the guy who went on
before me fucking crushed.
And uh,
there was this chick that I seen the
last time I was there and she was super
hot.
I fucked her and she was in the front
row and she brought her friends and her
friends look and then we're going to sit
in the front row when I went on stage.
So I was panicking.
I was like,
they're going to be like
right in front of me.
I was only like a year and a comedy,
a year and a half post.
And this guy went up who was
the MC was way better than me.
He would,
he was already better than me.
And I was like,
I conned this fucking book
it to making me a middle.
I was like,
it's just a cocky dude.
I can be,
I can middle,
come on,
I can middle.
Yeah.
So He lets me put it on.
This guy goes on stage and a
then and he stopped doing comedy.
It's really too bad.
He's a natural,
I don't remember his name unfortunately,
but he fucking killed.
And then I went after him and eight just
drive bricks of shit with no water for
20 minutes.
It was the most embarrassing
feeling I'd ever had in my life.
I couldn't believe how unbearable loss
and her and her friends were like looking
at each other and their friends would
lean over and say something like,
and then I could hear crickets and I'm
trying to be like extra loud because I'm
trying to like be trying to
bring it back to my side.
So like you like forced the punchlines
and the timing is all office even worse.
And my only experience
with being nervous before,
my only experience with
pressure had been fighting.
So when you know fighting and tournaments,
you know,
if you're nervous,
you just turn inward and you say,
this isn't what I want to do this,
I'm going to do this.
I'm going to do someone
to fucking explode.
I'm just gonna to fucking cool.
Terrified.
But you just get psyched up to go,
which is the worst thing you could ever
do on stage to be nervous and aggressive
and fucking and all introspective
and turned into yourself.
I don't give a fuck
what they take them out.
I'm just going to call the
worst mindset ever for comedy.
That's called being Carlos.
Mitzi?
Yeah.
I'm going to turn it in.
I'm going to explode.
The most fun.
I had a shoe.
Uh,
did you ever do shows without microphones?
Oh yeah.
Yup.
I remember parties ever do
a batch point of on the mic.
I did.
Yeah.
I used to do like a colleges around Boston
where they'd hire me and I'd be like,
well,
I'd be standing on a pool table.
I get one more.
I'm standing.
Did one in the cafeteria.
Standing
cafeteria chair a table.
Yeah,
Ricky table.
Like I couldn't move that
was there their stage.
I did a place in a in Florida
called the rathskeller.
They hired me to come down and it was
like one of my first road gigs and it was
the thing where it's like there's food
being served during the TVs are on every
like all that shit where
it's like the whole room,
everything is happening and I'm doing
standup and like somebody threw a hot dog
at me like five minutes into an hour.
Oh those gigs.
Important man.
All those shit gigs at Boston comedy
used to book and all those little weird
fucking places in New Hampshire.
You would drive an hour and a half up
to New Hampshire and do some weird bar
with a tinny sound system.
Those are so good though.
When you look back at it now,
like how important were those like for
developing your ability to like focus on
stage and kill and cut the
fat out of your act and
I would hope from own domain once I got
a gig up there and it was the first time
that we were a few years and
I drove home and I'm like,
all right,
this,
this matters.
Even though it was horrible,
I was like,
this matters it this.
Someday I will look back on tonight.
Know that like I learned
fucking something here.
Oh Man.
But it was,
you never want to come back.
Yeah.
You do those gigs and you just
like,
wow.
Like this is,
this doesn't even feel like show business.
It feels like I did a thing with this guy,
Scott Papic Curie.
He used to book the Mattapoisett
in this little tiny shithole.
Okay.
But it was a great little room
where I got to see teddy bears.
Ron,
by the way,
who was a fucking genius,
one of the best comics ever,
one of the best comics ever had one of
the best tonight show sets of all time.
Did you ever see his tonight show?
Sad.
It's fucking genius.
Click another guy where you like,
how could this guy not be in everybody's
mind as one of the greatest comics app?
And,
uh,
this guy,
Scott Pepper puree booked a Gig for,
he and I on block island and block island
was like an island outside of Rhode
Island,
I think.
And there's nothing there.
It's just drunk,
retarded fishermen.
And they are dumb as fuck.
And they're so drunk.
They are all of them.
There's maybe 20 people in the room.
All of them are so drunk.
They can't even keep their eyes open.
Their mouths are sliding.
I watch go high and we
have to do comedy for that.
And Scott gets up and starts
shitting all over them.
And he was not really,
you know,
he hadn't been doing comedy that long
then really probably shouldn't have been
on stage in this sort
of a situation anyway.
And I went on after him and they had
already turned their backs to the comedy
show.
Like half of them,
they're turned it back to just started
a conversation and we had a stay in,
um,
uh,
it wasn't,
it wasn't in a hotel room.
It was in a supply room.
They had two cots in the supply room
with no shower and there was a bathroom,
you know,
we could take like,
a a,
yeah,
a horse bath and you know,
we stayed in this little fucking supply
room until we could catch the boat back
the next day.
Oh Man,
I did so many of those little more.
I mean,
colleges where the [inaudible] site,
I got a Gig.
I know at the time.
Yeah.
At the time you're like,
all right,
I get a Gig.
I'm making 50 bucks or whatever it was.
But oh man,
brutal.
Bangor,
Maine.
I did a bunch up there.
Yeah,
I did a bunch for normal.
The Foa.
He had all these gigs in
western Massachusetts.
We're out there.
We had to drive 40 miles an hour cause
deer would jump in front of your fucking
car.
We five minutes.
You gotta to be careful
that you didn't die.
Like you get to these certain games.
Look,
sheer shows,
especially western mass near Amherst.
I remember there was a lot of two lane
roads where you would see dead deer all
over the place.
Right.
Fucking wreck cars.
I nailed one one night digital.
Yeah.
Just as just as ass had just gotten past
me and I did the thing where I gunned
it.
I'm like,
I wanted to swerve,
but the voice was like
gunning and I fucking hit him.
I watched him spin off into the woods.
You,
Greg and I started out probably
within like a week of each other.
Yeah.
Right.
Yup.
Back in Boston,
the old Boston stitches,
uh,
comedy community,
you know,
and a dude,
we,
you and I have gone
through some fucking can.
We went to some crazy
gigs in the beginning,
man.
We,
we went through together.
We went through like
the time for standups.
Yeah.
Well the,
the early days,
yeah.
We went through our personal darkest days,
but at the lightest time in comedy,
we thought the way
I see young comics today
and my heartbreaks,
because they got to
scrounge up stage time.
You and I,
you know,
I would say what less than
a year into doing stand up,
we were driving out and
making 50 bucks cash five,
six nights a week.
It was for me,
it was exactly one year.
I first got paid by normal
of foe to open up for um,
Warren Mcdonald peaking garden.
I don't know where it was.
It was some bar.
I was on a s like an apple box.
Like literally like standing
on an apple box doing comedy.
You can't fucking move and uh,
you know,
I had a good time and then the next
time I lurked for Lenny Clarke,
those are two times in a row.
I got super lucky.
Normally foe like caught me here.
Will you shut up you mother fucker man.
It was like all of us were like,
there was this ascension you would go,
you'd wait in line to get a spot on
comedy health open Mike Night Stitches,
comedy club,
George McDonald,
welcome to comedy hell
where the jokes always die.
The convenience.
It was this whole thing.
And,
and we ran out of booze,
comedy hell where you can fly,
fly as high as the light's on Broadway
or crash and burn and the fiery pit known
only as comedy.
Hell.
And that was step one.
And then you,
and then you would get like a guest spot
on a real show and then you would start
to get these like,
you know,
25 to $50 Mc spots where you were driving
the headline or somewhere and you jump
past all that shit because they would
send you out to feature and the headliners
couldn't follow you because you
were out of your fucking mind.
I mean,
you were nuts and uh,
and so they had to headline you.
So you started working like
the d rooms but headlining,
I'm,
so you started to get an
hour together super fast.
Yeah,
I had to,
I had a sink or swim.
Those times when,
uh,
Greg,
it would make agreements
to steal each other's shit.
We were bombing
say,
dude,
you got my whole act.
If you're eating it,
pick up there,
feel free to just,
and he would come back to that blow
job jokes hills if you go back to p,
but you might want to wait,
let the heat,
but the heat dyad of that joke,
it was fun for us because we
knew we would neither one of us.
Shit.
There was a a point in time where both
of us were doing like middling gigs and
we really didn't have the time.
We really didn't have
a real solid half hour,
so it's just sometimes you just,
when you,
when were you,
when you're a young comic and you
slip in the beginning of your set,
like the odds of you pulling
stuff out of the fire.
Oh yeah.
I remember one time I was having a good
set and I knocked over a drink and I
didn't address it.
Yeah,
there was,
it just turned on me.
Smelled blood.
They knew I was scared.
They knew I was,
I was killing
all of them out there.
It's all about their
uncomfort and you denying.
I remember being I,
this was probably the cruelest
thing anybody ever did to
me when I was on stage.
It was like,
you know,
half filled room back.
It was always like the back of a Chinese
restaurant where they had a banquet
room that they just put
a microphone up and,
and call it a comedy night and I'm up
there tanking it and I'm not acknowledging
that I'm tanking it.
And during one of the silences that should
have had laughed rented after one of
my jokes,
I heard this middle aged woman
whispered to her husband,
I could hear a whisper and she just goes,
the poor bastard.
Oh,
worse than any heckle.
Oh God.
Jesus Christ.
It is,
it would be real hard when
we'd watch each other.
You know your watch a friend
eat dick in the beginning too.
Cause you know how devastating it,
you know,
there's some times where you know,
this guy is not going to pull himself
out of this and he has 15 more minutes to
go
watch.
I'm slosh through.
Is there a way out of it?
Do you,
what do you have to do?
Like do you just have to
stop or do you just pets?
We would go,
yeah,
that's where we'd steal anything.
I Great Joe.
I knew that there were grenades that
I had in my waistband that were Joe.
Just take the fucking top off and
lob it and you're back in the game.
We would help each other.
There was a time where I was headlined
in where I had no fucking business
headline and there was no way.
I barely had 40 minutes and they were
letting me headline these rooms and I
would have to stretch it all
out and if something went wrong,
man,
it went wrong hard.
That's,
there's no better motivation
to creating new material.
Then when you just,
those shows happen and you just
fucking half to get to a work.
Like you need more weapons,
man.
You weren't on a weapons too quick.
You're up there dying.
Well,
especially like you can do
the hour when it's going well.
You can take that one bit
and you can stretch it out,
add shit to it.
You're here,
you're doing improvisational
jazz and that our fills up.
But when they're not laughing,
all of a sudden it's like concentrate,
everything shrinks down.
And now what you had as 35 minutes,
you just ripped through in
17 and now you're scared.
So you're tense and then you got
nowhere to go except the crowds.
So you start fucking with a craft.
They don't like you now does that they,
they don't like you.
You're not making them comfortable.
So there's not like a nice flow of energy.
And so yeah,
the early,
yeah,
feel it.
And the thing about Boston is,
and I think it was Kinda
unique to a lot of,
uh,
common other comedy cities
is it is a punchline town.
It's Bam,
Bam,
Bam.
You know,
they don't want to see something esoteric.
They don't want to see a storyteller.
They want you to grab them and just
smack them around and then walk off stage
with your hands in the air.
Well,
there,
there were guys that were doing
it that we're so good at the best.
Yeah.
We came up in an error where,
you know,
we've,
I've talked about this a hundred times
on the podcast and people always go,
yeah,
we know that we're really good comedians.
Back then,
I don't think people even understand
what it was like a utopia.
Boston was like this
standup comedy utopia.
There was at one point in
time there was five clubs
in a tiny little area,
seven night a week club.
Yeah,
I remember there was just that
one block of warrant warrant,
Nick's comedy stop.
And then there was duck soup and
there was a comedy connection.
And then Mike,
Mike Clark had the comedy club and the
Charles play house above the comedy.
And then on the weekends you
cut over to Dick tardies,
comedy ball,
50 yards away,
craziness.
And then you get in your car and you
drive down the stitches on comm ave.
It's like,
Holy Shit.
And the best part really was,
um,
and those were for short sets.
You doing five,
seven minutes with a big club.
Those were the big ones.
But then you and I would get,
and this is the thing
people don't get today,
is that we would get it for a year.
We get either you get my car,
I get in yours.
We dragged providence one night for a
1520 minutes set for free all the time.
Then we go to Hartford one night,
then we go to Worcester one night,
then we go to Maine.
One night we would go anywhere.
They'd give especially a longer set,
and then you know,
we were lucky enough to come up in a
time where the word comedy in front of a
place drew a crowd.
You didn't need to have a big name.
They just were comedy crazy.
And we just happen to be dropped in the
middle of it in a city that was a closed
system.
They didn't have headliners
come in from out of town.
So the local,
there were four or five big
local headliners that drew
and the and the and the
club's.
Otherwise they only booked
based on do you crush?
Are you funny?
Are you original?
So it was a meritocracy and no one ever
thought they were going to get famous
there.
What career,
if someone used the word career,
people would have linked
with them confused,
like what are you talking about?
All anyone wanted to do
was become a big Boston colic.
Yeah.
It's like the fame that you wanted was
just the being accepted amongst your
peers and having crowds come to see you.
That's it.
That's what everybody expects to
see you I think wasn't until later.
I think for us it was just,
I can't,
it's like,
you know when your first fucking a girl
and you can't believe she's letting you
fuck her after jerking off
for three straight years.
That's what it was like when
I was doing standup in Boston.
They're allowing me these stages that
I've watched since I was a teenager in all
this and I'm on it and
they're letting me talk.
That was it.
That's all I needed.
You know,
one of the first guys I ever saw
do a live set was Tom cotter.
Tom Cod was one of the first guys.
He's our buddy from Boston is a great
guy and he was in like some sort of a,
the first time I ever went out some
sort of an open mic night and uh,
and,
and he was like the first
guy that everyone on stage,
I remember that.
I swear to God,
same thing.
He was like a not,
he had started maybe
two years ahead of us.
That guy always used to bum me out.
And the reason why I used to bum me out
cause he was so fucking funny to hang
out with,
but he wanted to take it down
a notch and he wanted to like,
oh maybe,
maybe I shouldn't go so
dirty and maybe I should.
And you wanted to go do it.
That's you.
When you're at your best,
you're a pervert.
Crazy twisted.
P is,
he is one of the most twisted
dudes and I don't want to,
I'd rather have him on,
we should him on and do it
together because his stories,
the shit that he would do,
I can't,
I just can't say it on the air
and I can see anything on the air.
But the Shit Tom Cod are dead.
It was what the first guys I know that
would walk around with his balls hanging
out of his pants.
Yeah.
One of the first guys like no one
was doing that back when we were 20,
you know,
we were like 21 or whatever
the hell we were at.
Tom Carter's walking around with
his balls hanging out of his pants.
Jesus man,
it'd be a Christmas party and all the
comics are there and he and he would have
the hands on his hips still.
It wasn't like he was hiding.
Oh No.
And uh,
I remember at one point we were at
somebody's house and there was a dog,
it was a Oliver's dog and it was a,
he had rescued one of those,
a grey hounds.
I think Tom was putting a dill pickle
up its ass in the middle of the party.
Like we were both beyond children.
We were like fucking,
we were like a collection of bad kids.
Yeah.
It was the fun part of the fun of having
a guy like Tom cotter too is because
you knew that he would like
do something like that.
You knew he would want up things.
Yeah.
You knew if there was a bunch
of comics hang it around,
Carter would find a way to
make something fucked up.
I always felt like he kind of
pulled back on stage though,
you know?
Well he,
yeah,
he um,
in terms of practical jokes and
like guys like Kevin Knox May,
he rest in peace was one of
those guys just so fucking funny.
Offstage and so me cotter and Nazi or
working at a place in Maine called the
laughing lobster,
which started to have slow business and
suddenly burnt down in the middle of a
wet summer.
And so we're up there
and we're staying in,
there's a condo complex
that we're staying at,
which was pretty upscale and they got
a pool and it was all these hot fucking
chicks from Montreal to
come down to that part of,
of,
of Maine.
So we go,
we're going to go down to the pool
and I don't have my bathing suit.
And I were like,
fuck it.
You got boxer shorts,
she's where your boxer shorts down.
So they head down and I
walked down to the pool.
I opened the gate and I walk in and it's
packed and there on the far end of the
pool,
and I may get about halfway down the
pool and they both stand up and start
screaming.
Greg,
what are you doing in your underwear
at the whole fucking bull says
red faced and ran back to the god
set me up the whole
[inaudible]
cheer up fucking human being.